you gotta put up to it applies to okay
this is sick who was the worst texture
the worst texture mellow very slow on
her reply okay we have to stay on mellow
to make sure he ain't changed numbers
hands on what you're talking about
probably probably brawn like life advice
sometimes D way has a little bit of a
different perspective because he's the
oldest one out of all of us not to me he
had kids first you know I mean so I
remember when I had little Chris and I
was asking him you know about this about
that best person to be stranded on a
deserted island with stranded on a
deserted island with it's probably Braun
it's probably Braun and that's because
he like he is like very like routined
and like he knows going on my team or
not like that but you could imagine his
locker like everything is like where
it's supposed to be everything he's very
like he's meticulous very very
meticulous and he's the guy that like as
soon as you get to any location I don't
care where it is he want to know what
the Wi-Fi is he not using like Braun not
using his phone no data no he's not
using his phone unless he connected to
the Wi-Fi who was the worst person to be
sure at out a deserted island with hmm
it might be mellow you'll know I know
and this is why because if you want a
deserted island you would actually at
least want to be able to talk to the
other person get you with you no I'm
saying you want to be trying to figure
out how we gonna get off this island and
mellow is gonna be nowhere to be found
that's my mellow is gonna be nowhere to
be who was the worst playlist the worst
playlist probably be way probably do
well because if if you got to play this
plan he probably gonna play a song that
he didn't made he didn't create it it's
not a thing that D way has not done what
I mean so I'm sure he got like a few
tracks out there or something like that
yeah you could be listening you could be
listening to rowdy rich you could be
listening to Drake J and then next thing
you know D gonna put itself in there on
the thing most likely to get to the
free-throw line most likely to get to
the free-throw line this one this one
cuz he'd be out there playing football
absolutely playing football playing
basketball come through running people
over and stuff like that like most
likely to hit the game-winner I mean we
all can sort of do that but Melo does
that too yeah melot melot and I actually
seen like a clip of that recently or
something like that to say like he got
the most game went so I'm kind of chief
he got the most game winners out of
anybody I think since he came into the
league
my question what team did these three
almost done three yeah
all-star team clarified there was a
maybe in the a team you we are almost
played an all-star team together done
with you yeah